do you know who composed that piece that
you're practicing no who me
I don't believe and what's a composers
name Fred ballinger and you what's your
name Fred ballinger
daddy you will not be bored because I
have arranged the full service for you
you're going to have a massage sauna
checkups with the doctor every single
day to help you get back in shape by age
getting in shape is merely a waste of
time
gosh you guys have got a strange
friendship no it's a good friendship and
then a good friendship you only tell
each other the good things did you take
a piss today four drops you same more or
less more or less yes it must be a good
place to relax it's only the place to
relax
you still directing or composing
mushroom no no I'm retired I'm sure
you've not forgotten how it's done
no I haven't forgotten how it's done
ceiling what do you do all day friend
well they tell me I'm apathetic so I
don't do anything don't you miss your
work not at all I miss my wife you
didn't know the first thing about my
mother you never bothered to take care
of her she loved you and so she forgave
you no matter what happened she still
wanted to be with you who are you who
it's what I always asked myself a son
I don't owe anybody anything I did it
myself
you say motions are overrated emotions
above I've got not so
you're right music is all I understand
because you don't need words and
experience to understand it it just is
for Mature we haven't even man on see
400 but in Osaka meter house renovations
Crispian he can't not imagine flack
applause meter soviet alpha in done is